en el último vídeo de la nefrona
hablamos de las diferentes partes de la
neurona y de cuál es podríamos decir
moléculas son reabsorbidas por el cuerpo
en las diferentes partes y recuerda que
en el túbulo contorneado proximal
hablamos de la glucosa y de aminoácidos
y de sodio siendo re absorbidos también
hablamos de la parte ascendente del asa
de él hablamos de sales de sodio potasio
y cloruro siendo re absorbidas en el
tubo lo contorneado distal había calcio
y otras moléculas pero por lo menos en
mi mente cuando lo aprendí por primera
vez me preguntaba cómo sucede eso como
bombeamos estas moléculas activamente
especialmente en contra de su propio
gradiente de concentración lo que haré
en este vídeo es profundizar más en lo
que está pasando exactamente en los
bordes de estos túbulos para de hecho
permitir a estos iones ser transportados
selectivamente fuera del lumen o del
interior de estos tubos
o ser reabsorbidos del filtrado el
mecanismo es de hecho razonablemente
similar en las diferentes partes de la
nefrona pero veamos cada parte porque
cada una está re absorbiendo diferentes
tipos de moléculas
y no hablaré de todas las moléculas solo
te daré un sentido de las cosas
empecemos con el túbulo proximal aquí si
fuéramos a hacer un acercamiento de esta
parte
déjame dibujar el interior de una
nefrona el interior de una nefrona
podría verse algo así este es el
interior
aquí es donde está nuestro film
justo aquí
de hecho déjame dibujarlo un poco
diferente dibujar el interior de esta
manera el túbulo próxima al tiene estos
pequeños bordes que sobresale algunas
veces conocidos como bordes en cepillo
déjame escribir esto esta parte interna
nuestro lumen este es el luz
y ahí es donde está el filtrado el
filtrado glomerular viene en esta
dirección
este es nuestro fiel
de este como puedes imaginar es el
interior de la nefrona y luego los
bordes del túbulo están hechos de un
conjunto de células esta de aquí es una
célula aquí está otra célula ésta es
otra célula obviamente esta es una
sección transversal de hecho debería de
ser como un cilindro irá alrededor de
esta manera esto es solo para darte una
idea ahí hay otra célula tal vez este es
el lado basal justo aquí
y cuando decimos basal podemos imaginar
que es como la base de una célula esas
son palabras importantes que aprender
tecnicismos el lado de las células que
está encarando el lumen o que está
encarando el interior de nuestro túbulo
este es llamado lado apical
y tal
y a este lado normalmente se le conoce
como lado vaso lateral o lateral basal o
esta membrana si ves esto como membrana
será la membrana
hola
y estos mismos nombres se usan sin
importar en qué parte de la neurona
estén estos lados si en la próxima o en
el asa dl o en la distal en el otro lado
de las células tenemos nuestros
capilares peri tubulares
y ese es otro tecnicismo nuestros
capilares peri tubulares se ven de esta
manera de hecho también son células los
dibujaré de esta manera son porosos esto
de aquí este hecho flujo sanguíneo esto
de aquí es
cree
esto de aquí es
no dibujaré con muchos detalles las
células de las paredes capilares solo
quiero darte la idea de cómo las
moléculas son transportadas fuera del
lumen como son reabsorbidas de manera
selectiva este es el
lar
y
y nuevamente es un tecnicismo pero peri
significa alrededor como el perímetro
peri tubular significa alrededor de los
tubos estos capilares van alrededor de
los tubos si fuéramos a mostrarlo en
esta imagen tenemos estos capilares que
van alrededor de los tubos así que
cuando las moléculas son secretadas o
reabsorbidas fuera de las de from us
irán adentro de esos capilares esta es
nuestra membrana contorneada proximal
ahora pensemos en lo que pasa con la
glucosa lo que pasa es que de hecho
tenemos bombas de sodio potasio en el
lado vaso lateral de estas células
esta es una bomba de sodio potasio solo
dibujaré una aquí
quizá quieras ver el vídeo de la bomba
sodio potasio tengo todo un vídeo
explicando la pero la idea aquí es que
el sodio déjame dibujar partículas con
carga de más 1 ahí se enlazan al
interior de esto el atp llegará y cuando
se enlace a la parte adecuada de esta
proteína cambiará su forma su
conformación y después la proteína
esencialmente se cerrará de este lado y
se abrirá de este otro y mandará cuando
está en esa conformación el sodio no
quiere enlazarse tanto a la proteína y
saldrá cruzara la membrana basolateral y
luego llegará a la sangre y en el caso
contrario cuando la bomba sodio potasio
está en esta configuración abierta la
dibujaré aquí cuando está en esta
configuración abierta
hice todo un vídeo acerca de esto en
este punto el potasio quiere enlazarse a
ella al potasio le gusta enlazarse a
ella quizá se enlaza por aquí
esta es una simplificación eso hace que
la proteína cambie su conformación no
requiere atp en ese punto y regresa a
esta conformación
y luego el potasio ya no quiere
enlazarse y es liberado porque la
proteína ahora tiene una forma distinta
la idea general es que el sodio se
enlaza el atp se enlaza el fosfato del
atp se va eso cambia la geometría de la
proteína
está ahora el sodio quiere ser liberado
y ahora el potasio se quiere enlazar
cuando el potasio se enlaza regresamos a
la conformación original y el producto
final de esto es tenemos al sodio siendo
expulsado de la célula y tenemos al
potasio siendo bombeado al interior y
este es transporte activo
trans
por ti
go
y porque es transporte activo porque
usamos atp para mover al sodio en la
dirección contraria de su gradiente de
concentración para seguir bombeando al
sodio fuera de la célula
y luego el potasio ingresa puedes casi
imaginarlo pasivamente no necesita atp y
esa es la razón por la cual esto es
conocido regularmente como atp
sodio
potasio lo que significa que es una
proteína o una enzima que rompe atp
rompe atp y utiliza esa energía para
cambiar su forma para bombear al
exterior sodio y al interior potasio
este es solo un repaso de lo que
aprendimos en esos vídeos pero como nos
ayuda a eso a por ejemplo sacar glucosa
de nuestro lumen bueno tenemos otras
proteínas por aquí y sólo haré el
ejemplo de la glucosa digamos que
tenemos una proteína aquí y llamamos a
esto el término general para esto es
ccoo transportador os importador con
trans
x
o sí
por a
thor sin portador significa que
transfiere dos tipos de moléculas en la
misma dirección con transportador
significa que una molécula quiere
atravesar debido a su gran ente de
concentración y la otra molécula como
que lo acompaña en el paseo así que
puedes imaginar que estamos bombeando
hacia fuera activamente sodio y si
estamos bombeando sodio hacia fuera
activamente aquí en el lado vaso lateral
eso hará que tengamos una baja
concentración de sodio en este espacio
de por acá una
baja concentración de sodio hay entre
más bombeamos al exterior
esto será menor hasta que finalmente
será menor que la concentración de sodio
en el lumen así que el gradiente de
concentración del sodio si el sodio
si no hubiera membrana aquí el sodio
querría atravesar esto para de alguna
manera sustituir a todos los odios
perdidos acá el sodio querría cruzar si
no hubiera barrera
y las células aquí quieren tomar ventaja
de que el sodio quiere fluir a favor de
su gradiente de concentración el cual
está sucediendo debido al transporte
activo de aquí pero utiliza esa energía
del sodio que fluye a favor de su
gradiente de concentración para de hecho
transportar en este caso para también
transportar algo de luz
para visualizar lo puedes imaginar una
proteína en esta membrana apical tengo
una proteína así esto es solo para tener
algún tipo de visualización quizá tienes
más sodio en este lado
que en este lado es más probable que el
sodio se enlace aquí
quizá la glucosa se enlace aquí esto es
solo una simplificación pero cuando se
enlazan esta proteína cambiará su forma
cambiará su tamaño para parecerse más a
esto cuando se enlazan y ahora el sodio
estará acá y la glucosa estará acá
estamos esencialmente en el interior de
la célula ahora y en esta conformación
no quieren enlazarse tanto aminoácidos o
demás cosas que estén en la proteína y
son liberados cuando son liberados
entonces la proteína cambiará su forma
otra vez de regreso a esta conformación
de aquí y puede repetir el ciclo
nuevamente pero todo esto está
estipulado en la idea de que hay más
sodio aquí para toparse con este punto
para hacer que esta reacción ocurra el
sodio fluirá a favor de su gradiente de
concentración está llevando a la glucosa
de paseo y esencialmente
centra ción de glucosa se elevará aquí y
si hacemos esto poroso a la glucosa para
que la glucosa pueda atravesarlo y
entonces luego la glucosa sí esto se
torna lo suficientemente elevado
simplemente fluirá a favor de su
gradiente de concentración hacia la
sangre es decir fluirá gradiente abajo y
exactamente este proceso está pasando
quizá no exactamente con la glucosa pero
en toda la neurona si vamos al asa de l
si vamos a la parte ascendente justo
aquí donde intentamos quitar a las sales
en la misma idea déjame dibujarla
digamos que eso de ahí
luz men
esta es una célula que hace la pared del
lumen estamos en el asa de en la hora y
tienes una bomba de sodio potasio aquí
tienes al sodio bombeado hacia afuera y
al potasio bombeado hacia adentro pero
de hecho los canales de potasio tienen
fugas por lo que el potasio puede por lo
regular moverse en cualquier dirección
por eso lo que le sucede al potasio no
es tan importante pero entonces la
concentración de sodio se vuelve baja
aquí tenemos nuestros importadores aquí
uns importador aquí y justo como en la
glucosa pero esta vez el sodio quiere
entrar
justo como con la glucosa pero aquí
intentamos transportar iones de cloro y
potasio así que eso es lo que vamos a
unir eso es lo que va a aprovechar el
gradiente de concentración del sodio
tendremos potasio y tendremos iones de
cloro y de hecho este es importador aquí
es llamado con transportador sodio
potasio cloro o n k
c2 por sus siglas en inglés y de hecho
en la segunda variación que obtienes en
la parte ascendente de la za de l al
final de cuenta acabarás con mucho cloro
aquí de hecho potasio en ambas
direcciones pero mientras esto sea
poroso al cloro y esta concentración se
vuelva lo suficientemente alta el club
saldrá y ayudará a hacer a la médula tan
salada junto con el sodio
lo mismo ocurre en el túbulo contorneado
distal ahí se trata más bien de calcio y
el mecanismo es un poco diferente si
estamos en el túbulo contorneado distal
estos bordes que sobresalen estos sólo
están en el túbulo contorneado proximal
estos bordes de cepillo pero acá y sólo
para que lo sepas
este concepto donde usamos un gradiente
de concentración que está siendo
conducido por una especie de transporte
activo para transportar otras moléculas
este es llamado transporte activo
secundario
trans
corte
tipo
tío es bueno saberlo y luego terminando
en el túbulo conformado distal digamos
que este de aquí es el lumen
tenemos células en ambos lados de eso
creo que entendiste la idea general el
distal es un poco diferente digamos que
esta es la célula y este es un capilar
peri tubular esta es nuestra
cree
lo que tenemos aquí es que nuevamente
estamos bombeando sodio hacia afuera
con la bomba sodio potasio hay un vídeo
entero de esta y bombea potasio al
interior así que terminas con mucho
sodio aquí la membrana apical que encara
al lumen es porosa al calcio la misma
concentración de calcio que haya aquí
estará acá aquí tienes tus iones de
calcio justo así flotando alrededor y
aquí lo que tienes es un anti portador
nuestra concentración de sodio en la
sangre será elevada porque lo seguimos
bombeando hacia afuera y entonces si
dejas que el sodio fluya a favor de su
gradiente de concentración volverá a
entrar entonces quizá aquí
tienes algo de sodio que fluye a favor
de su gradiente de concentración entra
nuevamente y luego cuando el sodio
ingresa puedes imaginar esto como algún
tipo de puerta rotatoria hace que el
calcio salga puedes intentar
visualizarlo por ti mismo como una
proteína aria eso
imagino un tipo de puerta giratoria el
sodio hace que la puerta gire el calcio
está en la otra parte de la puerta y
este es aventado este llamado
an
por está dor
porque va en diferentes direcciones pero
nuevamente es un transporte activo
secundario porque la única manera en la
que éste puede funcionar es sí tenemos
transporte activo mediante atp si
tenemos transporte activo de sodio fuera
de la membrana vaso lateral en todos
estos casos
espero encuentres esto útil es más
detallado de lo que normalmente
encuentras en como la nefrona está
bombeando moléculas fuera del lumen a
capilares peri tubulares pero para mí
hacen los conceptos mucho más concretos
me ayuda a interiorizar lo que la
nefrona está tramando